die bundesländer wollen kontakt
beschränkungen und masken pflicht
verschärfen nur über weihnachten und
silvester sind lockerungen geplant
us präsident macht nun doch den weg frei
zur amtsübergabe wahlsieger beiden
präsentiert erste mitglieder seines
kabinetts und china startet ehrgeizigen
mond mission als dritte
raumfahrtnationen wollen nun auch die
chinesen mondgestein zur erde wühlen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen schön dass sie dabei sind wie
auch norbert lehmann für den
sportstandort von mir weihnachten und
silvester in corona zeiten wenn es nach
den bundesländern geht dann dürfen
maximal zehn erwachsene aus
verschiedenen haushalten zusammen feiern
abgesehen davon wollen die
ministerpräsidenten und minister
präsidentinnen morgen im kanzleramt
darauf drängen die korona maßnahmen zu
verlängern und so verschaffen david
sauer fast ihre vorschläge zusammen der
teil shutdown soll bis zum 20
dezember verlängert werden für
betroffene betriebe sind weitere
entschädigungen geplant die masken
pflicht wird erweitert sie gilt künftig
auch vor geschäften und auf parkplätzen
im schulunterricht soll sie in regionen
mit einem incidents wert über 50 ab der
siebten klasse gelten ab erster dezember
strengere kontakt beschränkungen private
treffen sind auf den eigenen und einen
weiteren hausstand zu beschränken
maximal fünf personen
wer kann soll sich vor weihnachten
einige tage in quarantäne begeben um
angehörige zu schützen die man während
der feiertage trifft an weihnachten und
silvester wird dann gelockert
erlaubt sind treffen bis maximal zehn
personen kinder unter 14 ausgenommen
empfohlen wird in der silvesternacht auf
feuerwerk zu verzichten auf belebten
straßen und plätzen soll das böllern
untersagt werden
mehrere bundesländer haben angekündigt
den beginn ihrer weihnachtsferien
vorzuziehen so dass jetzt fast
bundesweit die schüler ab 19 12 zu hause
bleiben können und so das
infektionsrisiko siegt was an
weihnachten dann tatsächlich gelten wird
das entscheiden morgen bund und länder
zusammen über den weg dahin berichtet
andreas künast
damit wenigstens weihnachten aussieht
wie immer knipst berlin den
kurfürstendamm an und die politik ein
paar kontakt beschränkungen aus davon
ausgegangen dass weihnachten das fest
aller feste ist für die deutschen dass
die länder einen gemeinsamen vorschlag
vorlegen ist eine lehre aus dem
stundenlangen streit vom letzten mal
das ist etwas anstrengender für uns ich
habe gestern abend fünf stunden video
schalte gehabt mit 16
ministerpräsidenten gemeinsam die
textarbeit gemacht haben aber am ende
haben wir 16 zu null für uns ein gefühl
so sollten wir angehen wir sind uns ja
einig dass wir so weit als möglich das
bildungswesen unberührt lassen wollen
dass zum beispiel der handel in der
vorweihnachtszeit weiterlaufen soll
und damit ist auch sehr klar dass man
sich umso mehr auf andere bereiche
beschränken muss ob der kanzlerin die
beschränkungen der länder diesmal
reichen wird die frage der morgigen
runde ihrer fraktion reichen sie nicht
wir kriegen aus der fläche viele
rückmeldungen aus dem bereich schule
dort wird gesagt die schulbusse sind
voll warum gibt es kein wechsel
unterricht warum ist nicht mehr im
digitalen bereich möglich ich denke mal
da sind die länderchefs insbesondere in
der verantwortung
auch der bayerische landeschef zweifelt
findet treffen zu zehnt höchstens an
weihnachten richtig es wird passiert ist
da noch mal zu überlegen sein bei dem
service pack wird weniger eine 13
familie gefeiert da wird mehr mit
freunden gefeiert
da muss man nochmal überlegen ob die
zahl da wirklich angemessen ist die afd
lehnt alle vorschläge der länder ab an
silvester nicht mal berlin für den
weltfrieden und das umwelt und das klima
und alles da sind wir schon lange
dagegen die stille nacht wird wohl
stiller als sonst aber so dunkel wie
befürchtet wird sie nicht theo koll in
berlin müssen wir uns darauf einstellen
dass morgen möglicherweise noch
schärfere beschränkungen beschlossen
werden als das was jetzt in den ländern
geplant ist das könnte passieren denn
die hausherren hier im kanzleramt und
ihr kanzleramtsminister haben in all den
monaten immer für eine härtere linie
plädiert man erinnere sich nur an die
vergangene woche und den vorschlag dass
sich jedes kind künftig nur noch mit
einem freund oder einer freundin treffen
dürfe auch jetzt ist zu hören dass das
kanzleramt nachschärfung bei den kontakt
beschränkungen durchsetzen will
beispielsweise könnten die
weihnachtsferien dann nicht wie von den
ländern angedacht haben 19 beginn
sondern schon einige tage früher eben
wurde gemeldet das ist offensichtlich um
den 16
dezember gehen soll dabei also quasi um
den vorweihnachtlichen quarantäne effekt
zu verlängern
auch einige länder chefs und chefinnen
hätten heute schon wieder aus dem einen
waren die maßnahmen zu strengen dem
anderen zu entspannt also vieles scheint
hier aufwendig vorbereitet aber es
bleibt auch noch genug stoff für eine
lebhafte runde morgen
vielen dank nach berlin tierkörper dass
die zahl der neuinfektionen in
deutschland ist im vergleich zur letzten
woche leicht gesunken
laut robert-koch-institut meldeten die
gesundheitsämter 13.500 54 neue fälle
binnen 24 stunden das sind 865 weniger
als vergangenen dienstag die zahl der
todesfälle im zusammenhang mit dem virus
stieg um 249 soweit die zahlen für ganz
deutschland zwischen den ländern gibt es
allerdings erhebliche unterschiede
sachsen zum beispiel kam anfangs gut
durch die pandemie
doch im oktober stieg die zahl der
infizierten rasant gleich drei
landkreise haben aktuell mehr als 300
neuinfektionen pro 100.000 einwohnern
innerhalb von sieben tagen stefan kech
und thomas bärsch berichten aus dem
erzgebirge im erzgebirge stecken sich
derzeit viele menschen auf arbeit an wie
bei seidel moden ist home office fast
nirgends möglich denn kleine
produzierende betriebe sind das
wirtschaftliche rückgrat der region eine
katastrophe wäre es wenn hier corona zu
schlagen wird
wir halten abstand gehalten hygiene und
wir halten in den bereichen wo wir näher
als ein meter fünfzig aneinander heran
gehen setzen wir die talks maske auf
doch wie sieht es nach feierabend aus
das erzgebirge und wir alle wie wir da
sind sind sehr voll mit ja das heißt
familiäre zusammenkünften dort eine
rolle spielen
eine mentalitätsfrage also vielleicht
ist das ja aber auch eine
mentalitätsfrage insoweit kaufland oder
was weiß ich vorher gehen und gucken sie
mal wer sich an die regeln hält und
werden nicht zum beispiel haben wir sehr
viele klage führten wieso ist denn das
so hier in der gegend
dabei soll das erz gewirkt hat sind das
sind ja alles gestandene leute die haben
früher im schacht gearbeitet und es sind
alles starke jungs und die kriegen das
gar nicht
der umstand dass im erzgebirge viele
ältere menschen leben für zu schweren
corona verläufen die klinik in erlabrunn
hat sieben beatmungsgeräte und alle
werden schon jetzt gebraucht im moment
müssen wir schon sagen dass in allen
krankenhäusern hier im landkreis aber
auch in den ähren gelegten im
regierungsbezirk die
behandlungskapazitäten fast ausgeschöpft
sind weihnachtsland erzgebirge
das steht sehr in frage die
landesregierung spielt gerade mit dem
gedanken eine ausgangssperre zu verfügen
schon öfter haben wir in sachen corona
über den schwedischen sonderweg
berichtet dort gab es bislang kaum
verbote nur empfehlungen vielleicht
besser so meinte auch hierzulande
mancher jetzt allerdings greift auch
schweden härter durch denn die zahlen
sind eindeutig 6400 tote im zusammenhang
mit dem virus wurden registriert das
sind umgerechnet fast viermal so viele
wie in deutschland
im april war kobe in schweden sogar
todesursache nummer eins kann man bernd
über regeln die völlig neu sind für das
land die einkaufsstraßen belebt wie
immer aber keine masken pflicht in
stockholm angesichts rasant steigender
infektionszahlen reichen die bisherigen
empfehlungen im kampf gegen korona nicht
mehr aus jetzt also vorschriften vor
allem größere versammlungen sind
verboten
personen dürfen noch zusammenkommen so
eine einschränkung gab es noch nie in
schweden aber wir müssen das virus
kontrolliere werden
strengere vorschriften und eine erste
vorsichtige abkehr vom viel beachtet und
schwedischen sonderweg die lage ist
ernst und so gibt es nur noch hier
kontakt beschränkungen oder besuchs
verbote in pflegeheimen
ich finde das gut und ich glaube dass
alle sich jetzt etwas mehr
zusammenreißen und den restriktionen
jetzt auch folgen ich glaube der grund
dafür dass es jetzt härter ist
dass wir die spitze eines berges
erreicht haben und man ist deswegen
gezwungen jetzt strenger zu sein
schulen oder restaurants sind noch immer
geöffnet aber pro tisch dürfen maximal
acht leute platz nehmen erste kleine
einschränkungen und ein appell des
ministerpräsidenten
ando musste wie lasst unseren
zusammenhalt und unser
verantwortungsbewusstsein stärker sein
als das virus und dass wir besiegen wäre
dies bisher schweden weicht heute etwas
ab von seinen sonderweg ein harter
kurswechsel ist es noch nicht
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat klar
gestellt dass rassismus zu einer
fristlosen kündigung führen kann auch
bei einem betriebsrat
der mann hatte einen dunkelhäutigen
kollegen mit affenlauten verhöhnt die
menschenwürde werde angetastet wenn
jemand nicht als mensch sondern als affe
angesprochen werde entschieden die
richter
solch eine rassistische
menschenverachtende diskriminierung sei
nicht mehr vom recht auf freie
meinungsäußerung gedeckt drei wochen
sind seit der wahl in den usa
vergangenen drei wochen in denen der
präsident die machtübergabe komplett
blockiert hat jetzt lenkt er doch ein
von seiner niederlage will donald trump
noch immer nichts wissen aber er
twittert dass die behörden sollten tun
was getan werden muss heißt trump gibt
den weg frei für die amtsübergabe an joe
biden der künftige präsident präsentiert
noch heute erste mitglieder seiner
regierungsmannschaft aus den usa
berichtet ines trams es scheint als habe
präsident trump die signale gehört all
seine klagen gegen die stimmauszählung
gescheitert und der druck nahm zu den
übergang zu joe biden zuzulassen
zuletzt hatten die republikaner in der
wahlkommission von michigan ihren
widerstand aufgegeben
unsere pflicht ist klar wir haben nicht
die autorität eine prüfung der wahl zu
verlangen
die zertifizierung zu verzögern oder zu
blocken
kurz danach macht die chefin der behörde
die für die amtsübergabe zuständig ist
den weg frei dass beiden team soll nun
zugang zu informationen und ministerien
bekommen kann
unterstützt das per tweet eine übergabe
wäre im interesse des landes
erleichterung auch bei republikanern es
ist zeit zu feiern
dankbar zu sein für die stärke unserer
institutionen waren die letzten wochen
doch atemlos und pessimistisch da war
die rede vom verfall unserer republik ja
gar den bevorstehenden kollaps derselben
beiden stellt derweil sein kabinett
zusammen erfahrene profis die für
internationale zusammenarbeit stehen so
soll transatlantik angeli blinken
außenminister werden john kerry ist
vorgesehen als klimabeauftragte janet
yellen könnte als erste frau an die
spitze des us finanzministeriums
vorrücken jahren einen präsidenten der
das land auf einen anderen weg geführt
hat einen weg durch den wir weltweit
respekt verloren haben dieses team kann
den respekt nun zurückgewinnen spricht
derweil auf twitter weiterhin ohne
beweise von wahlbetrug und er macht klar
seine niederlage gesteht er noch nicht 1
waren wir noch mal nach bei ines trams
in washington wofür steht dieses
regierungsteam von drogen joe biden
steam steht in jeder hinsicht für eine
abkehr von frank joe biden will eine
regierungsmannschaft so vielfältig wie
amerika mit mehr frauen mehr schwarzen
und mehr einwanderer vor allem steht
sein team aber sofern es bislang schon
bekannt ist für erfahrung es sind
langjährige weggefährten von joe biden
die lange schon im politgeschäft sind
unterwegs sind und die auch gut vernetzt
sind in der welt so soll nun schluss
sein mit trance außenpolitischer
leitlinie amerika zuerst beiden und sein
team wollen international wieder auf
multilaterale zusammenarbeit setzen
viele im team sofern es wie gesagt
bislang bekanntes stehen für das
sogenannte washingtoner establishment
mit ihnen gemeinsam will joe biden und
schnellstmöglich viele viele
entscheidungen von trump zurückdrehen
offen allerdings ob joe biden der neue
präsident so in der lage sein wird
republikaner vor allem trump anhänger
im engeren sinne mitzunehmen man darf
nicht vergessen das land ist geteilt die
vorderste aufgabe des neuen präsidenten
ist es das land zu einen
danke für diese einschätzung aus
washington ines trams von schockierenden
bildern spricht der französische
innenminister ein polizeieinsatz gegen
migranten in paris stößt auf heftige
kritik
gestern abend hatten flüchtlinge etwa
500 zelte auf der place de la république
aufgestellt aus protest gegen die
politik der regierung
die polizei löste das lager schnell auf
berichten zufolge sollen mehrere
menschen geschlagen und getreten worden
sein
immer wieder werden in paris in und um
paris illegale flüchtlingslager geräumt
auf der erde ist china schon eine
großmacht jetzt will die junge
raumfahrtnation auch im all boden
gutmachen
heute startete ein unbemanntes
raumschiff richtung gut um von dort
gesteinsproben zu holen das gelang
bisher nur zwei ländern 1969 erstmals
den usa als mit apollo 11 die ersten
menschen auf dem mond landeten 1970 dann
die premiere für die sowjetunion die
sonde luna 16 brachte einige steinchen
mit und jetzt es china dran
rolf roller berichtet der
weltraumbahnhof venture auf der
südchinesischen insel hainan gleich
erfüllt sich hier ein traum von china
der traum mit den usa und russland in
der raumfahrt gleichzuziehen
die trägerrakete langer marsch ist
erfolgreich gestartet die mond mission
beginnt
bisher kann ich ihnen sagen ist die
mission ein voller erfolg
stolz sind sie auf den staat china will
mit hilfe der raumsonde schange fünf
steine und staub vom mond einsammeln das
besondere der bohrer soll nicht nur
einfach material von der oberfläche
zusammen kratzen sondern vielmehr zwei
meter tief in den mondboden eindringen
die forscher hoffen so mehr von der
entstehungsgeschichte des mondes zu
erfahren
das ist der ultimative test für die
raumsonde und wir hoffen sie besteht ihn
die mission gilt als eine der
kompliziertesten die chinas raumfahrt
unternommen hat lange haben sie an der
mehr als 800 tonnen schweren rakete
gearbeitet
im chinesischen staatsfernsehen feiern
sie die mond mission wie ein nationales
großereignis
viele träumen davon einen chinesen auf
den mond zu schicken
die mission zeigt wie china sich der
welt präsentieren will
14 tage bleibt die sonde auf dem mond
mitte dezember soll sie dann wieder auf
der erde landen
das hinspiel hatten die großen drei zu
null gewonnen und ein weiterer sieg
gegen den belgischen meister
das achtelfinale wäre dann zum greifen
nah dafür sorgen soll torjäger erling
holland nach seinem jüngsten viererpack
in der bundesliga in topform
wer wenig erling holland soll es heute
abend richten er ist der garant für tore
in der bundesliga schoss holland bislang
zehn tore in sieben spielen ähnlich
erfolgreich trifft er in der champions
league beim hinspiel in brügge schoss er
zwei der drei dortmunder tore und dieser
20-jährige sagt vom 16-jährigen yussuf
amoco er sei das weltgrößte talent nun
das wird sich zeigen
zumindest in den heutigen kader hat
lucien favre mukoko berufen
seit samstag ist er jüngster bundesliga
profi heute könnte er als jüngster
champions league spiele
die geschichte eingehen der angriff
allerdings ist stark besetzt beim bvb
mit einem sieg an diesem vierten
gruppenspieltag gegen brügge stünden die
dortmunder die die tabelle anführen
schon mit einem bein im achtelfinale
ein zeichen gegen rassismus gestern
abend in der national football league
die tampa bay buccaneers gegen die los
angeles times ein historisches spiel
denn erstmals kam eine komplett mit
schwarzem schiedsrichtern besetzte crew
zum einsatz
siebenmal gold bei den paralympics
elfmal alpine ski weltmeisterin
heute ist eine ganz besondere
auszeichnung für anna schaffelhuber
dazugekommen fahrer sportlerin des
jahrzehnts gewählt wurde die 27 jahre
alte regensburgerin die von geburt an in
komplett querschnittgelähmt ist von den
zuschauern und von einem expertengremium
des deutschen behindertensport bundes es
ist vor allem am ende der karriere
einfach nur schön weil man wirklich ab
die komplette karriere zurückblickt und
die kann sich sehen lassen besonders die
fünf goldmedaillen 2014 in sotschi
ich wusste im vorfeld ist es möglich die
einzelnen zu gewinnen aber ich sage
jetzt mal dass ich alle fünf gewinnen
das habe ich mir dann doch sage ich
jetzt mal nicht erträumt vor einem jahr
ist anna schaffelhuber vom
leistungssport zurückgetreten
sie arbeitet jetzt als lehrerin
gratulation von uns ja und sie hätte
natürlich auch eine feier mit publikum
verdient
es kann morgen etwas sonniger werden wo
und wie sehr erzählt gleich gunther
tiersch marietta slomka begrüßte im
heute journal um viertel vor zehn und
hier übernimmt morgen christian sievers
wir danken für ihr interesse und
wünschen ihnen noch einen entspannten
abend auf wiedersehen wollten sie es gut
[Musik]
hunderte zuschauer es gibt in china ist
beim wetter aber mit etwas mehr
sonnenschein können wir morgen durchaus
rechnen
die temperaturen bleiben in mitteleuropa
bei etwa fünf bis zehn grad aber im
süden von frankreich da wird es
tatsächlich morgen mal so richtig mild
bis zu 15 grad teilweise noch ein
bisschen wärmer und dauerfrost haben wir
vor allem im norden von skandinavien und
in russland und bei uns natürlich nachts
im osten und süden sind es morgen früh 0
bis -4 grad aber sonst im norden und
westen bleibt es frostfrei ist würde
eine trübe nacht mit vielen nebelfeldern
und da kann ab und zu mal ein bisschen
sprühregen rauskommen dann könnte es
natürlich sehr glatt werden bei den
frost klaren himmel haben wir vor allen
dingen in sachsen da scheint auch morgen
wieder herrlich die sonne am nordrand
der mittelgebirge
das schiebt sich dann dort nach
norddeutschland richtung küste auch
davids heller bei diesem schwachen süd
bis südwestwind ja im süden bleibt trübe
in den niederungen um auf den bergen
oberhalb von 600 metern scheint
wenigstens die sonne und die
temperaturen ändern sich da kaum vier
bis elf grad werden erreicht am wärmsten
wird aber hier im schwarzwald oben auf
den bergen 12 grad unten an der donau
hier zum beispiel in bayern bei nebel
eben nur null grad ja und am donnerstag
geht es ähnlich weiter aber es wird ein
bisschen regnen norddeutschland freitag
mehr in der mitte und am samstag kommt
schon wieder mehr die sonne raus es
bleibt trocken
ich wünschen noch einen schönen abend
und machen sie's gut